foreign
[Music]
tells computers what to do and they do
it
but when a computer finds patterns or
correlations in data and figures out an
unexpected Solution on its own that's
what's called machine learning
we experience machine learning all the
time these days Netflix Spotify and
other streaming services use our prior
searches views and listens to predict
what we want to see and hear
spam filters learn which emails to label
are spam Banks use machine learning to
identify fraudulent transactions
these programs are using accumulated
data and algorithms to become more and
more accurate as time goes on the
machines are learning so to speak and
machine learning isn't just affecting
the online aspects of Our Lives it aids
farmers in deciding what to plant and
when to harvest and it helps autonomous
vehicles improve the more they drive
now many people confuse machine learning
with artificial intelligence or AI they
are related but they're not the same
machine learning extracting new
Knowledge from data can help a computer
achieve artificial intelligence
as we head toward a future where
computers can do ever more complex tasks
on their own machine learning will be
part of what gets us there
[Music]
thank you